قالت واشنطن ان ارسالها مقاتلات وبرجه
حربيه الى الشرق الاوسط هدفه ردع ما سمته
اي عدوان الايراني المحتمل وانها تدرس
بحسب وسائل الاعلام نشر جنود على متن سفن
تجاريه اثناء مرورها عبر مضيق هرمز من
ناحيته بحث قائد الاسطول الامريكي الخامس
مع الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
ضمانه تدفق التجاره العالميه في الممرات
المائيه الاقليميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي المؤشرات التي
تستند اليها واشنطن في حديثها عن عدوان
الايرانيين المحتمل في منطقه الخليج وكيف
يمكن ان تستقبل طهران مثل هذا الاتهام ثم
ما مدى واقعيه نشر الولايات المتحده جنودا
على السفن التجاريه في مضيق هرمز وعلى اي
نحو يمكن ان ترد ايران على مثل هذه الخطوه
ثم ما بدا ارتباط هذه الخطوه بلقاء قائد
الاسطول الامريكي الخامس بالامين العام
لمجلس مجلس لدول مجلس التعاون الخارجي وما
هو دور الخليج في اطار هذه التطورات
[موسيقى]
بالتزامني مع استقبال الامين العام لمجلس
التعاون الخارجي قائد الاسطول الامريكي
الخامس وبحثهما تعزيز الامن البحري
بالمنطقه وتامين حريه الملاحه البحريه
وكذلك تدفق التجاره الدوليه ومع تاكيد
واشنطن انها تهدف من ارسالها مقاتلات
وبارجه حربيه الى الشرق الاوسط دفع الى
ردع اي عدوان ايراني محتمل بحسب تعبيرها
وان زياده الوجود العسكريه الامريكي في
المنطقه تاتي في اطار العمل مع حلفائها
لحمايه مضيق هرمز نقلت وسائل اعلام
الامريكيه عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان الجيش
الامريكي يدرس امكانيه نشر جنود على متن
سفن تجاريه اثناء عبورها مضيق هرمز في
اجراء غير مسبوق لوقف ما سماه استيلاء
ايران على السفن المدنيه ومضايقتها
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع معنا في بدايه في
هذه الحلقه من واشنطن
كبير الباحثين في معهد سوفان للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامن الدولي اهلا بك سيد
السؤال الذي يتبادر للذهن ما المؤشرات
التي دفعت واشنطن الى القيام بهذه الخطوات
العسكريه او النيه في القيام بهذه الخطوات
ولعل اجدها هو امكانيه نشر جنود علامه
السفن التجاريه تعبر مضيقه هرمز ما
المؤشرات لماذا
شكرا اولا للاستضافه
ان هذه الخطوه المحتمله هي ليست غير
مسبوقه تماما ربما تتذكرون في الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه الولايات المتحده
ارسلت سفن حربيه لمرافقه السفن التجاريه
عندما كانت ايران تهاجمها لحرمانها العراق
من موارده التجاريه اذا هذه خطوات
مشابهه لكنها اذا ما حدثت الان فستكون
بمثابه تصعيد وسوف يكون وضع اي جنود
عسكريين امريكيين على متن سفن تجاريه هذه
السفن ليست محميه وليست مدرعه وبالامكان
ان تهاجم من قبل قوات الحرس الثوري
وقواربه
المنتشره هناك وربما هناك احتمال ايضا ان
يتم اسر افراد عسكريين امريكيين انه
بمثابه الرد على عدوان ايران والذي تمثل
في بيع مسيرات
لروسيا وايضا قيامها مؤخرا بمهاجمه سفن
تجاريه والاستيلاء على تجاريه وحر فيها عن
مسارها
والادعاء بان عليها ان تدفع رسوما
وانها تتسبب بضرر على البيئه كلها
الذرائع غريبه
وحقيقه تحاول بان ايران تحاول التصدي
للضغوط الامريكيه
وايضا محاوله خلق مشكلات لدول الخليج
ولولايات المتحده والدول الاوروبيه هذه هي
الاجابه الامريكيه لمثل هذه النشاطات
الايرانيه ولكن سيد كان دائما هناك تواجد
عسكري امريكي في هذه المنطقه في هذه
المياه وتم توجيها الاتهام في وقت سابق
لايران بانها اختطفت او حجزت بوارج وقطع
بحريه تجاريه ولم يتم التصرف عسكريا مع
ايران ما الذي سيتغير مع هذه الخطوه
شعورا بان الحضور العسكري الامريكي في
الخليج لم يرضع ايران وهذا هو السبب
الولايات المتحده كان لها حضورها العسكري
في الماضي والذي عززته ايضا بعد ارسال
مقاتلات
35 ثم طائرات عشره وايضا
انواع اخرى من الاسلحه ومع ذلك استمرت
ايران في مهاجمه السفن في محاوله
للاستيلاء عليها او حرفي عن مسار احيانا
اطلقت هذه
السفن نداءات استغاثه فهبت البحريه
الامريكيه لنجدتها ففر الايرانيون وفي
احيان اطلقوا النار ايضا عندما اقتربت
السفن الامريكيه من الموقع اذا هناك شعور
بان لو ان
المتحده تكون موجوده مباشره على متنها
السفن التجاريه وقريبه منها هذا سيرضع
ايران من هزمتها طبعا ايران لم ترتدع من
قبل فواصل تشعر انها بحاجه لتعزيز وجودها
لارسال اشاره الى ايران بان عليها ان
تتوقف عن مهاجمه هذه السفن باعتقادك سيد
قدمان هذه الخطوه الاخيره هل جاءت
بالتنسيق مع حلفائها في المنطقه الحلفاء
الخليجيين خاصه بعد لقاء الطرف الامريكي
بالامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي هل
هناك ارتباط باعتقادك
انها قضيه طويله الامد بعض بلدان الخليج
وخاصه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودوله
الامارات العربيه
بدات في الماضي القريب بالشك في مدى
التزامي الولايات المتحده بامن الخليج
ولذا تولد شعورا لدى السعوديه والامارات
بان الولايات المتحده تغادر المنطقه وتهتم
بالصين اكثر او ربما اهتمامها يقل على
الاقل عندما لم تزود امريكا المنطقه
بالسلاحه احيانا وعندما لم تحمي الرئيس
مبارك السعوديه والامارات بدات تشعر بان
الولايات المتحده لم تعد معنيه بحمايه
الخليج والدفاعي عنه ضد ايران وضد الفاعل
الاخرى فكان هذا ربما اشاره من الولايات
المتحده لتع وجودها وارسال المزيد من
القوات وان وضع جنود على متن السفن تجاريه
سوف يؤكد لبلدان الخليج والشعوب الخليج
بين الولايات المتحده شكرا تم بامن هناك
بعد دبلوماسي وسياسي ايضا لهذه الخطوات
الاستراتيجيه والامن الدولي استقبل الان
ضيفي ارحب بهما من طهران محمد صالح صدقيان
الباحث المتخصص في القضايا الاقليميه ومن
بيروت الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت اهلا
بكما ابدا بضيف من تراصيد محمد صالح
صدقيان اجراءات امريكيه في في مياه الخليج
خاصه ما يتعلق بهرمز غير مسبوقه نشر النيه
في نشر جنود على على السفن التجاريه في
المقابل ايضا ايران تقوم بمناورات اقل ما
يقال عنها بانها غير معلنه من قبل وفي
مضمونها استعمال صواريخ قد تصل الى 600
كيلومتر بالاضافه الى اتساع مدى هذه
المناورات كيف نفهم الصورتين سيد محمد
صالح
مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك والمشاهدين ان
يعتقد بان هناك شيء معلن من خلال زياده
التواجد الامريكي والتجهيزات الامريكيه
والطائرات الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه وهناك
شيء غير معلن الشيء المعلن هو هذا الذي
تفضلت به من اجل مراقبه سير الملاحه
البحريه في مضيق هرمز والمياه الخليجيه
وفي المحيط شمال المحيط الهندي لكن يعتقد
بان هذا التواجد هو من اجل
مواجهه اولا اي احتكاك محتمل يمكن ان يحدث
في هذه المنطقه وزياده قوه الرد على
الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه النقطه الثانيه
ان الولايات المتحده تعتمد في سلاستها على
قاعده القوه
احتكاك ربما يحدث بين اي مع الجانب
الايراني او ربما
تهديد اسرائيلي لان نتنياهو مضغوط في داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وبالتالي
لمواجهه اي او اداره لاقل ربما هذه
الاداره افضل توصيف افضل من المواجهه
لاداره اي احتكاك محتمل يمكن ان يكون في
هذه المنطقه النقطه الثانيه هو ان
الولايات المتحده لازالت تقود
مباحثات مع الجانب الايراني في سلطنه عمان
علي باقري معاون وزير الخارجيه الايراني
الان في سلطنه عمان وربما الاستئناف
المباحثات
لتنفيذ صفقه تبادل المعتقلين بين الجانبين
والافراج عن الوداع الايرانيه المجمده
وبالتالي السياسه الامريكيه تعتمد على
قاعده القوه وربما
اعاده تواجد او زياده التواجد الامريكي في
هذه المنطقه ينسجم مع هذه التطورات
وبالتالي ان يعتقد من الطبيعي جدا ان تكون
الولايات المتحده تستخدم سياسه الردع
وتعزيز الردع في هذه المنطقه لكن في
الجانب الاخر ايضا الايرانيون لا يريدون
ان
يدفعوا كلف باهظه في حال حدوث اي احتكاك
محدود او مواجهه او اي شيء من هذا القبيل
لكن اصل التواجد الامريكي او التعزيز
الامريكي في هذه المنطقه اني لا اعتقد
بانه يخص حركه الملاحه لانه يستهدف شيء
اخر دكتور عبد الله كيف تقرا المشهد
اجراءات وقائيه من الطرفين ام ان هناك
امرا طرا او سيطرى
يعني هو استعراض القوه الامريكيه وهو ليس
له مبرر في اعتقادي يعني امريكا تريد ان
يكون لها وجود ما عندها استراتيجيه واضحه
في الشرق الاوسط حمايه اسرائيل فقط
الحلفاء الخليجيين منذ سنوات نشعر
بالتراجع الامريكي والانكفاء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حسب الدراسه الوثيقه
السماويه
للاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه الامريكيه التي
صدرت في اكتوبر الماضي تعطي اهميه منخفضه
لمنطقه الخليج والشرق الاوسط ككل الاولويه
هي الصين احتوائها ومواجهتها وكذلك روسيا
في اوروبا ولهذا السبب يعني مستغرب ما
تفعله امريكا الان ارسال منذ الشهر الماضي
يعني صار لنا شهر الان
16 واف 35
حصيده الدبابات والان يعني تصريح مسؤولين
لوكاله الاي بي امس بوضع يعني عناصر
عسكريه في سفن تجاريه يعني هذا هذا غير
مسبوق وهذا غير مفهوم لن يطمئن دول الخليج
يعني اجتماع
القائد الاسطول الخامس امس مع امين عام
التعاون الخليجي هو فقط جزء من العمل
الروتيني للتنسيق والتعاون
الدكتور
بين هذه الخطوات المعلنه الامريكيا وبين
اللقاء الذي تم بين قائد الاسطول الامريكي
وبين امين عام مجلس التعاون الخليجي لا
تربط
يمكنك ان تربط ولكن الهدف واضح بان هناك
استياء امريكي من السلوك الايراني يعني
ايران لها حضور في سوريا وهناك يعني
تقارير في الاستخبارات ومراكز الدراسات
الامريكيه بان هناك تحالف ايراني روسي
لمواجهه امريكا في شمال شرق سوريا هناك
ايضا محاولات ايران للسطو على ناقلات نفط
هناك ايضا برنامج ايران النووي الذي يبدو
انه متعثر يعني ما يفعله ما تفعله اداره
بايدن هو انها اخذت قرار على ما يبدو
بانها لا فرصه الان قبل الانتخابات
الامريكيه للتوصل الى اتفاق نووي هذا
امريكا تصاعد بشكل كبير وايران ترد ايضا
بشكل مستفز في مناورات في الجزر
الاماراتيه المحتله طنب الكبرى طنب الصغرى
وابو موسى وتشتبك مع الكويت والسعوديه حول
حول حقل يعني على ايران ايضا ان تعيد
التفكير بحساباتها لم يمضي اربعه اشهر على
المصالحه والتقارب مع السعوديه وايران
وتبدو ايران الان انها نفضت يعني غزلها
وبدات عادت الى السياسه التي فيها استفزاز
وفيها مواجهه وهذا لا يخدم ايران اذا
بالفعل تريد ان تعود الى عقارب الساعه
تعيد الى الماضي فلن تبني الثقه الثقه
تبنى بالجلوس والتفاوض حول حقل الدره بعدم
استفزاز دول الخليج للتو بدانا الان يعني
نتقارب مع ايران وخاصه تبادل السفراء مع
السعوديه واعاده العلاقات فلماذا ايران
تسلك هذا السلوك الذي لا يطمئن ولا يبني
الثقه وهي في موجهته مع امريكا هذه منصه
طرفا الدكتور عبد باستمرار هذه نقطه مهمه
ايضا اسال عنها ضيفي من طهران الدكتور
محمد صالح صدقيان
بدايه ايا كانت نوايا الجانب الامريكي في
اتخاذ هذه الاجراءات
ما مدى خطوره هذه الخطوه خاصه في ظل وجود
ملفات التي ذكرها الدكتور عبد الله قد
تعيد بشكل او باخر كما الدكتور عبد الله
عقارب الساعه الى الوراء اي وجود ملفات
تثير توترا ما مع دول المشاطئه في الضفه
الاخرى
المنطقه هي التي ادت الى هذا التصعيد اما
فيما يخص التازين في في مضيق هرمز او من
جراء الوضع الامريكي او الاستقدام طائرات
جديده وباردة ومارينز وما الى ذلك كان
يعتقد بان الايرانيين يعني يريدون ان يكون
في يكونوا في جهوديه عاليه من اجل مواجهه
اي احتمالات او اي مواجهه محتمله في هذه
المنطقه
النقطه الثانيه هم يريدون تكثيف المساعي
الدبلوماسيه والجهود الدبلوماسيه لانجاح
المفاوضات التي تتم في سلطنه عمان من اجل
تنفيذ صفقه تبادل المعتقلين والافراج عن
الوداع الايرانيه المجمده من اجل خلق
ارضيه تريدها الولايات المتحده وتريدها
ايران ايضا لربما التوصل الى تفاهمات بشان
الملف الايراني لان الجانب الامريكي ربما
محتاج الى هذه قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه في عشرين اربعه وعشرين
والايرانيون ايضا محتاجون لمثل هذه
التفاهمات
الاهم في كل هذه الحسابات ذكرتها الان هنا
اسال الدكتور عبد الله كل هذه الحسابات ما
تعلق منها بالحسابات الدوليه في اطار اوسع
او الحسابات الامنيه والعسكريه المجمع
اتخاذها واجراءها من قبل الجانب الامريكي
في المنطقه نتكلم عن ربما ما يمكن تسميته
بصفحه جديده صفحه سعوديه ايرانيه الى اي
مدى هذا اختبار لهذه الصفحه وكيف لها ان
تؤثر اذا ما اثيرت او تطورت الاحداث بناء
على هذه الاجراءات المزمعه اتخاذها من قبل
الجانب الامريكي
صحيح صار مهم جدا اخ عبد القادر يعني انا
عندما كنت في الدوحه عندما في عشره مارس
اعتقد كان عندما يعني صدر في الاعلام بان
هناك مقاربه ومصالحه يعني في العلاقه بين
السعوديه وايران والصين هي الوسيط طبعا
هذا جزء اخر من من زياده القوات العديد
القوات الامريكيه لطمعن الدول الخليج
بالدرجه الاولى
والنقطه الثانيه ايضا لارسال رساله لدول
الخليج بان ليس من مصلحه دول الخليج
التحالف مع الصين في عقر دار النفوذ
الامريكي وهذا طبعا نقطه يمكن تعيد عاده
الحسابات بالدرجه الاولى عند صناع القرار
في البيت الابيض ومجلس الامن الوطني
والعياده السبب اتى ما استشار الامن
الوطني جيك صلفا اكثر من مرتين خلال
الشهرين الماضيين خاصه الى السعوديه انا
سميت التقارب السعودي الايراني لم اكن من
المتفائلين بسرعه هذه المصالحه وكنت حذرا
وسميتها يعني مرحله اختبار نوايا
للعلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه وبالتالي
العلاقات الايرانيه الخليجيه
وراينا الان هناك في تصعيد امريكي انا
اصفه بالتهور يعني كيف تضع يعني عناصر
مسلحه على بوارج او على عفوا على سفن
تجاريه كما ذكر كونفيرشل شيبس وليس على
ناقلات نفط يعني ايران لا تحتجز سفن
تجاريه بل يعني تتهم بانها احتجزت او او
تعرضت
ناقلات نفط في مضيق هرمز فكيف
ستعزز هذه المحاوله تقنع ايران ترضع ايران
بدرجه الاولى تطمن دول الخليج التي ايران
التي امريكا اداره ترامب مثلا لم تحرك
ساكنا عندما قصف
باسلحه ايرانيه منشات ابجاج وخريص في
السعوديه في 2019 التراجع الامريكي
الانسحاب من افغانستان هذا لا يطمئن زياده
عدد يعني اخر مره اعطيك انا بس مثال على
التراجع الامريكي اخر مره كان في ناقله
حامله طائرات امريكيه في منطقه الخليج
لامريكا تبقيها باستمرار نمت كان في
نوفمبر 2020 يعني منذ ذلك الوقت ما عندنا
حامل الطائرات هذا ليس تعويض ارسال الفين
مارينز وبحار وطائف 165
وبارجه ومدمره وسفن انزال هذا لا يعوض
التراجع الامريكي والانكفاء والاتجاه نحو
اسيا مطلوب استراتيجيه امريكيه متكامله
عوده الى الاهتمام بمنطقه الخليج خاصه بعد
الازمه في روسيا وتراجع الامدادات النفط
مطلوب من ايران التعقل اكثر نحن نريد
علاقه وديه مع ايران وايران تريد علاقه
وديه معنا ولكن تصرفات وسلوك ايران لا
يعزز الثقه ولا الامل بان ايران بالفعل
تحولت واصبحت اكثر تعقلا في مقاربتها خاصه
بعد المصالحه مع السعوديه والانفتاح
والسيارات
الدكتور محمد
مره اخرى الفكره التي طرحها الجانب
الايراني فيما يتعلق
ما الذي تحتاجه ايران ان تقوم به اكثر حتى
تصبح هذه المبادره واقعيه وتقنع بها بقيه
الاطراف في المنطقه باعتقادك في دقيقه لو
تكرمت
انا عندما تحدثت عن امور ربما غير معلنه
لوصول مثل هذه التجهيزات الامريكيه
الجديده والطائرات الى مضيق هرمز ربما هي
تستهدف المبادره الايرانيه التي طرحتها
للحوار والتعاون والتحالف البحري بين
ايران ودول الخليجيه لا اعلم هذه خطوه
استفزازيه خصوصا وان الولايات المتحده
تتعامل الان مع ايران وفق الخطه جيم وليس
مع الخطه التي تستخدم الخيار العسكري مع
ايران وبالتالي الخطه جيم كما قالت
المصادر الامريكيه تريد ان تتوصل مع ايران
الى تفاهمات
مؤقته تفاؤلات مكتوبه او غير مكتوبه
وبالتالي هذه الخطوه الامريكيه بوصول
طائراتها من اف 16 و35
والمارينز وما الى ذلك خطه استفزازيه ربما
تريد ان اقول ربما تريد ان تستهدف اي
تعاون محتمل بين ايران ودول الدول
الخليجيه او التحالف البحري او
التعاون والتنسيق بين الجانبين شكرا لك من
طهران محمد صالح صدقيان الباحث المتخصص في
القضايا الاقليميه وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من
بيروت الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]